Speaker 4: President Joe Biden is going to brief
the country on the state of our union, and today
I'm going to brief you about the state of the
David Pakman show. It's been an incredible year,
the second year of the COVID pandemic,
the first year of Joe Biden's presidency.
Economic uncertainty, vaccines, inflation,
other calamities. 2021 was an incredibly
strong year from the standpoint of the show,
and I can report to you that the state of
the David Pakman show is very, very strong.
Some say the best that we've seen. In 2021,
we added more than 200000 YouTube subscribers, not
the most we've ever added in a year, but the most
we've ever added in a non-election year, and that
is now putting us within striking distance of 1.5
million YouTube subscribers. Our friends over
at the young Turks have been really the standard
bearers for left wing YouTube channels for
a very long time, and I can report to you
with total peace and love that in the last few
months, The David Pakman Show YouTube channel
is receiving more daily views than the young Turks
main channel friendly competition. Their network
is way bigger than ours. We love everybody over
there, but just a reminder with a small team,
you can do some pretty amazing things
in terms of the audio podcast. Monthly
downloads are now at their historic peak. Our
previous peak was that crazy period between
the November 2020 election and the Trump riots.
That was our high watermark. We are at a new high
watermark now with the audio podcast the most
downloads a month in the history of the show.
We've got new platforms quickly growing nearly
100000 followers on Instagram, nearly 100000
followers on Tik Tok. We've launched YouTube
Shorts Content. Instagram Reels Content 2021
also saw the return of the David Pakman Show Town
Hall events hugely popular with our core audience.
But the year was not without some major
challenges. We received the 90 day monetization
ban from Facebook after our content was wrongly
flagged for spreading COVID disinformation,
something we would never do. But it was a big
hit to our revenue, thanks to the hard work of
nearly a dozen Facebook employees who are in our
audience. We were able to get that monetization
ban reversed in under a month, but it's a stark
reminder of how precarious these revenue sources
are. More recently, we got a 24 hour ban
and a community guidelines strike on Tik Tok
due to another false positive in a segment where
we criticized right wing actor Kevin Sorbo and his
opinion about health care. We were banned for 24
hours and now one strike closer to a permanent ban
from TikTok. And of course, we were targeted
by right wing conspiracy theorist Alex Jones,
who launched a brutal attack on my appearance,
on my eyes on my face. Discharged a number of
salvos against our bonus show. So we are up
against some major obstacles or obstacles in
attempting to move towards a sort of more media
literate, critically thinking society. Donald
Trump continues to deliver these erratic, febrile
screeds on a regular basis. His followers love it.
Fox News continues to spread disinformation,
sometimes spending 24 even 48 hours talking about
Hillary Clinton must soon be going to prison,
given all the crimes she supposedly committed.
Just boogeyman boogeyman of critical race theory
cancelations, Dr. Seuss. It's pervading right wing
media and their followers fall for it, a seemingly
on speed Don Jr., regularly inciting the most
bottom dwelling pond scum of the political right
in these apoplectic froth over misunderstandings
and distortions. And that's not going to stop.
Sadly, and it is sad, even some on the left fall
for the disinformation, many so-called leftists
wildly attacking me for being a supposedly
imperialist bastard. Despite my constant refrains
that I am against American intervention abroad,
in almost all cases, the facts do not matter
to too many people. But we will not give up
and we will continue to persevere because I see
the good in the independent media audience. I
see it in that 15 year old Canadian kid who
recently called in inspired so many of you
with his wit and his intelligence and his
curiosity. I see it in the people emailing me 20,
30, 40 times every day. Even though their emails
have been filtered into the trash for months,
they're still enthusiastically emailing me.
I see it even in the right wing troll callers
who we know are calling constantly because they
see us having an impact. That's why they won't
stop leaving me voicemails. They're worried
that we're talking sense and that people are
understanding it. That's The David Pakman Show,
I know, and that's why I can confidently tell
you today. The State of the Union know the state
of the show is as strong as ever, and it makes
me hopeful about the future of independent
media. Thank you, and God bless the United.